daily wire so the question that kept
coming up uh Stephen was you know well
you know whether it's Candace came out
and said you know I wanted to find out
what he had to say or Ben Shapiro came
well this is how negotiation works if
you don't like it you go back and forth
let's go how many times did you guys go
back and forth until it was like okay
you know you did a video you didn't
mention the company's name everybody's
trying to kind of guess who it is but
most people kind of knew it was daily
wire they were talking about and then
they came out Jeremy went through the
contract you know one by one by one and
then you responded then there's the
recording then there's this and then it
was like Hey Candace comes out Jordan
Peterson tweet delete all the stuff
that's going on right but the question
get the world's biggest high school I
get it but yeah the question for me is
how many conversations did you guys have
up until the point where it's like we're
not doing this yeah so I mean and not to
rehash like all that stuff because I
think people now kind of know like you
make your decision and I love Jordan
Peterson like Andrew like I'm still
friends with a lot of people over there
um the issue there was there was never
look the issue I always had was and I
said take me off the table because it
wasn't going to be a fit the issue was
with other people the primary issue you
never heard me talk about money and I
know as a business guy that's probably
like like nails on a chalkboard but it's
uh you know you can't penalize people
you can't put on 110 penalties on behalf
of big Tech literally 110 penalties
um but primarily if you have other kids
who are coming up like you can't punish
conservative content creators on behalf
of big Tech saying not only do you have
to be there you have to be monetized
which you know on YouTube right that's a
very different set of guidelines is
basically don't say anything offensive
ever all I can say is is uh there was
never anything that we went over that
involved that being eliminated like that
was the sticking point like okay get rid
of that no that that doesn't happen and
so we decided okay we're going to go uh
on our way and do it
um now we're focusing on what it is that
we can do what it is that we can change
and bringing in other people so from the
beginning of the conversation series
until decision was made is that like
five weeks it's two months three months
is there like a
months okay good so it's not like it was
a because some people are thinking hey
we're out of here we're done first
offered I can't believe you're doing
this I'm blasting your public okay so
that's good to know that's between you
and them you guys can you know that's a
conversation between you and the people
you were working with sure here's the
other question the issue is is when you
don't see eye down like look take it off
the take me away yeah the issue is the
punishment on behalf of big Tech really
issues like you know I've been
demonetized for this long yep that can
be red line and changed wasn't so that's
the issue it's like that was the issue
as far as okay this isn't going to
happen because of the big Tech penalties
and I understand it too by the way look
when you're in a war
and I mean that we are an ideological
war uh we really are we are at a
potential Tipping Point in this country
you need different kinds of people you
need different battalions and I get it
that some people want to work within the
platforms uh in order to change the
platforms well no one understands that
more than me because I've been there
since you know before there was
monetization actually my brother was one
of the first uh YouTube partners I think
in 2000
seven 2008 whenever they started it but
the issue is when the platform no longer
allows you to speak truth I'm not
looking to be removed from YouTube I've
talked about that uh and the people who
we've signed we want nothing to do with
whether they are on YouTube or not as
far as I'm concerned that's blood money
like I would and I don't mean it's blood
Money blood but I mean I don't want to
have to influence someone to play ball
with YouTube or Facebook or tell them
not to if that's what they choose to do
the issue is when you have a platform
like YouTube like Facebook that says you
know what you can't say uh for example
that there's myocarditis with young
people right or there could be potential
adverse effects of the MRNA injection
with young people when they say you
can't say that we're going to suspend
you you are now no longer able to speak
truth so we'll use those platforms as
long as they're available provided that
we're allowed to speak the truth but
when we get to the point and we've had
these conversations where we're like
well you want to quote the CDC on the
flu death today he's like well you still
want you want to be suspended for
another two weeks or hey do you want to
have Carrie Lake who's currently running
for governor it's like well you know
we're going to be suspended and miss the
election stream that night and we just
decided to let the cards fall where they
may it's it's reached that point
unfortunately yeah so that's so the so
the okay so I understand that so then
the question would be the following is
it fair to say that the uh like if you
were to announce if you were to say
right now who are the top I don't know
five six seven uh conservative media
companies out there you got Fox you got
daily wire who else would you put out
there would you put Blaze as one of them
as an option
I don't know I don't have access to
their financials it's a question I
couldn't answer so let's put aside the
financials that say influence I guess
let's just measure it by influence that
you and I can see who would you put as
like Prague are you I'm Prager using
that's part of daily wires now I'm
talking more like CNN MSNBC you know you
got it you know whoever they have on the
other side or like an eyeballs you're
talking views you're talking clout yeah
I'm talking about like if I say who are
the biggest podcasters today not
political at all okay you got Rogan you
got you know impulsive you got you know
whoever you know call her that you know
all these things they see not
necessarily political you can say these
are the most influential ones right
within the conservative side who would
you say are the top five most
influential media companies today
I mean this is on there yeah you name
them I mean if people consider them you
know conservative you'd have Fox on
there you'd have daily wire on there um
you know you probably have like a red
State Town Hall Salem it's a big one
okay yeah um very familiar with them uh
I I don't know krlas with Salem right
krlies with Salem kklas they do they
have like red State Town Hall a lot of
radio stations so they're really big uh
you know why I'm asking a question I'm
asking a question because I don't know
if there's enough of them that's what
I'm asking I think yeah that's the point
yeah so if there isn't enough of them so
you guys if I can get this uh if I can
get it right you're planning on building
a conservative media platform recruiting
other talent to come in under your
umbrella yeah to put that's what you're
trying to do yeah but it's a different
approach yeah and perfect this is why
it's different is um I don't need to do
it right so this is so uh for and then
I've done for a very long time I think
Ben is the best at what he does
certainly among them you'd have like
Mark Levin's up there of course at one
point Rush Limbaugh
um but Ben didn't do that until you know
daily wire happened before he was he was
working other places like Breitbart gold
um the issue is
when all these companies do it the same
the same way right it's the same it's
people talking about news and that's
fine but at a certain point you have to
ask if it's by Design now here's the
thing it's because these companies need
people to do that in order to and look I
can tell you this when I was uh working
at Fox News for like four and a half
years
changed my mind was when it was pitched
to every major publisher I've talked
about this it was pitched as a segment
at Fox News and people said that will
never work so it will never work people
want four or five minutes they want it
snappy right they want you in a quadrant
view one time I think it was on with
Lanny Davis or might have been Doug
shown on Fox news they had this in this
quadrant View and I was always getting
in trouble I'd always get called into
the second floor
but we're shocking we're in the same
room
and they have us on these like these
quadrant views I'm like why is he doing
I'm right I'm right there here I am and
so at the end of the segment I think it
was Lanny Davis I was like Hey Lanny
high five and I reached into his
quadrant so and they were like you know
you can't do that because people like it
to seem really International I was like
I don't really know if that's what
people necessarily want and so I say you
know what I'm going to go out and do a
comedy show which they said
conservatives don't really like comedy
this way at that point in time they said
uh you can't do what you're gonna sit
down with random people to have
conversations for an hour unedited two
hours I said yeah I remember when I
pitched it as a book although at that
point the term social justice Warrior
didn't exist or triggered so the term I
used was uh American Idiot because Green
Day was big at this point in time and I
separated between them and sort of the
modern leftist and they said no no the
only thing we can sell to conservatives
is the Doomsday books and it's not a bad
book but the Obama blueprint was a
really big book at that time they said
you have anything like this and I said
well that's not me so I don't need to do
like we can do them and do our show
right matter of fact we'd be more
profitable just doing that but providing
a platform for people who aren't looking
to make it big in the conservative space
but particularly people you'll see with
the people who we sign and the names of
someone who's done comedy
um you're Adam and you're very sorry I
almost said uh said Adam uh people who
can be who they are and reach a
different reach a different group of
people like there's a reason too like
the conservative demographic is it's
quite literally dying off unfortunately
and uh it's very lucrative to sell them
certain kinds of of messaging certain
kinds of content I don't mean immoral
but when people are precluded from
reaching them there are a lot of people
out there like me like Jill like our
audience the average viewer is a
20-something 30 year old uh college
educated male they're not tuning in to
Fox News they're not tuning into a lot
of you know AM radio but they are tuning
into what we do because it's it's a
comedy show and I don't mean a comedian
who does a show and you know that's
right like a lot of comedians they'll
host podcasts it's not a comedy show
exactly this is an entertainment show
and the reason we had to go and do it on
our own was it's never going to work and
then every time you sit at that side of
the table whether it's Fox whether
whoever it is they go can we change it
so that you can fit into the box this
way because that's our box and we want
to do the opposite and we don't have to
do it we can say what's your box what is
it that you are let's give you the
opportunity to let your freak flag fly
so I want to go on this I want to go a
little bit more on this but I want to
quickly the question I want to ask you
in a minute here is you're right you
don't have to do it but you are a voice
you do have a massive following and
there is a niche there is an emptiness
that we need somebody to do great if
you're going to do it and what's the
structure going to be different and then
you made a comment about Fox so the
question is one you don't need to do it
but you're choosing to do it so if
you're recruiting talent and you know
now know what daily wires contract is
because you've gone directly with them
yeah you now know what Fox's contract is
you now know what Blake's contract is
you you kind of got experience of the
top guys in the marketplace how they do
so that kind of gives you an edge to say
we don't want to do it this way we don't
want to do it that way here's what we're
going to do so my open-ended question
for you will be the following assume a
lot of people that love your stuff are
watching this and their talent they may
want to come and run with you okay and
they might want to say okay Stephen
let's come wrong with you here's what we
want to do what are some things a talent
is going to get from teaming up with you
that they may not get at other places
well here's the deal it's uh and he's
obviously so Gerald has seen several
conversations like this recently yes
uh but I will say this you know having
experience with okay with stand-up it's
a perfect example when you're doing
stand-up right when you start out you're
starting doing whatever it was like when
I was you're middling you know doing I
mean sorry when you're on the road
you're being paid you're getting a few
hundred dollars to Middle to right to
feature and then if you're a headliner
you know you might get 1500 for the
whole weekend and then you reach a
certain point where you're doing these
venues they give you a minimum guarantee
okay so this is not Reinventing the
wheel the minimum guarantee doesn't
matter if your your aunt your uncle and
your dad show up right or you say you
know what lower that guarantee and I'll
take a higher percentage of the gate uh
so when I do live shows I say like give
me basically the closest he can to no
guarantee and the highest percentage of
the gate that's all it is it's a sliding
scale you always need to have upside to
be incentive yeah
and especially when they're content
creators you always need to have some
ownership and autonomy in the realm of
Comedy or some people want more of a
guarantee so this side is more of an
employee this side is basically you're
doing a revenue split and depending what
it is that you want or need if it's
production if it's editing if it's
social media that changes the percentage
you can bet on yourself get a higher
percentage of the gate or we also have
options where there's a higher minimum
guarantee it's not Reinventing it this
is how it works in the entertainment
industry the only place it doesn't work
that way is in you know that I've
experienced is in the right wing uh the
right wing media sphere it's it's very
bizarre it's an anomaly so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]